and thanks for joining us at 11 i'm
denise feldas and i'm brian loftis we
are following the breaking news we first
reported earlier tonight a child found
dead inside a freezer the discovery was
made earlier today at a home on saddle
brook park drive which is near kerry and
lamb we have team coverage tonight
madison kimbrough spoke with neighbors
but first we do begin with victoria saha
with how police ended up finding the
child victoria
yeah brian and denise this all started
as a
kidnapping investigation and eight news
now has learned a man is in custody in
the with those charges his name is
brandon tozlin this 35 year old also
owns this home on the street you can see
crime tape is still up with the
discovery of the child's body there will
be an additional charge of murder
clark county school district police
received a report
that a
child who is in elementary school went
to school today with a note from her
mother in that note the mom said she was
being held against her will and did not
know where her preschool aged child was
and that child may be dead this prompted
an investigation with metro police about
10 o'clock this morning they observed a
male leaving the residence with a female
patrol officer stopped the vehicle and
detained the male who is a hispanic male
in his late 30's the female inside the
car is the mother of the
child who was at the school when police
interviewed the mother she said she
suffered abuse from the hands of her
boyfriend she also said she has not seen
her preschool son since december 11 and
she's been continuously asking about him
she also tells police she wasn't allowed
to leave the house and was told by her
boyfriend to not go into the garage a
search warrant led to police making a
gruesome discovery we entered the house
and discovered the remains of a
preschool aged child inside of a freezer
police believe the child has been dead
since december the boyfriend is not the
father of either of the children
involved
eight news now checked hoslin's criminal
record we did find he has several
priors that includes domestic battery
but that case was dismissed he's
expected to be back in court facing the
judge tomorrow morning reporting from
the east valley tonight victoria saha
live local now